so his name is Devin goda and he is the
third male model ever to appear on the
show ET on lines lauren zima was
exclusively on set asking the questions
that we all want to know how many abs do
you have because some people have a
six-pack yeah it's a lot Devin yeah I
think I have by eight or maybe a little
bit more than eight right now okay okay
so if a 29 year old former NFL player
turned model is easy on the eyes but he
also has a way with words in more than
one language
so I speak Slovak my mom's side is
Eastern European from Slovakia can you
say I love my new job on The Price is
Right I got too much dough bread dough
but uh you know I'm having a great time
here and he's heading for the end zone
where you'll find your new ass how did
the fam feel when they heard you got
this job they loved it my god we're very
close to my grandmother and she's a huge
fan
Devin you ever cuddle on a treadmill
because that's what everybody's thinking
about right now in the audience not that
they're gonna faint
every single right now I am single right
now perfect but if you're looking to
capture Devin's affections you may have
some four-legged competition his new
puppy Maddy I actually grew up on a farm
so like before all of this stuff I'm
kind of a farm boy like I love animals I
love being around nature can I see some
of your like looks into the camera like
what's a good model moment my go-to is
just yeah it's just a game so just know
it's just something like that we're
doing exactly what rusev exactly he
would love to transition into the acting
world his idol is Dwayne the rock
Johnson that's a good one to follow
[Music]